varios edificios oficiales en ruinas
autos calcinados e incluso calles
manchadas de sangre en la ciudad más
grande de kazajistán es el panorama de
la peor agitación política en el país
desde la caída de la unión soviética
hace 30 años
almaty fue el epicentro de nuevo de los
mayores enfrentamientos el miércoles y
el jueves con los manifestantes
asaltando instalaciones gubernamentales
una residencia presidencial y tomándose
el aeropuerto obligando a la cancelación
de vuelos a comienzos del viernes el
presidente casi me llamara tokáyev
afirmó que el orden había sido
restaurado confirmando que la policía
dio de baja a docenas de manifestantes
también dijo que murieron docenas de
miembros de las fuerzas de seguridad
pero las fuerzas kazajas también
pidieron ayuda desde el extranjero
después de que el presidente apeló a la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva rusia y a otros miembros de la
alianza regional a que envíen tropas al
país una maniobra que eeuu afirmó estar
monitoreando de cerca
tenemos preguntas sobre la naturaleza de
esta petición y si es una legítima
invitación o no no sabemos en este punto
enright junto con el mundo estaremos
vigilando cualquier violación de los
derechos humanos mientras tanto el
presidente tokáyev declaró que el
gobierno restauraría el rubro de algunos
de los precios del gas licuado siendo el
aumento de esta materia prima el
detonante de las marchas
pero puede que sea ya muy tarde
estas manifestaciones han evolucionado
en un descontento mayor contra la
autoritarismo y la corrupción asuntos
que el gobierno no ha abordado con éxito